hey youtubers is Charlie so George are
Martin made people a little bit crazy
last week when he said that Dan and Dave
are killing characters in Game of
Thrones season 5 that are still alive in
the books his operative words were
killing and characters as in multiple
characters so what I did is I just made
a list of my most likely candidates it's
mostly a mixture of main characters and
side characters what I think he was
implying is is that these are characters
that we've already met meaning that
they're not gonna be like the new
characters they introduced so I I tried
to not include characters that weren't
gonna be sync for the first time in
season 5 add to that there are a couple
characters that I left off the list on
purpose just because their status in the
books is a relative question mark that
being said this is all speculation but
just careful for spoilers and if you do
want to talk about you know really big
characters and whether or not they might
be dying based on what happens in the
books just please use spoiler tags real
quick reminder new round of the giveaway
I'm giving a copy of the season 4
blu-ray all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video real simple so let's go I'm
just gonna start this based on area like
north south King's Landing marine etc so
here we go King's Landing Loras Tyrell
most likely candidate he's a really big
character he has really deep
relationships with the other main
characters but I feel like the show
could kill him off without ruining any
of the logical endgame there are a
number of logical end points for the
series but I feel like they could kill
Loras off it would be a big WTF and it
wouldn't ruin any of those endings the
same goes for the rest of the people on
the list it's like who can the show lose
for maximum WTF impact that won't ruin
any of the best potential endings so
moving down to the South in Dorne Bronn
my number one candidate without getting
too specific we see him and Jamie
getting to fight with darkness soldiers
so clearly he's going to be involved in
a conflict in Dorne bran is one of the
best fighters on the show right now one
of the new characters in Dorne
Aereo is probably one of the best
fighters in the Seven Kingdoms if not
the world I think it would be badass if
they became like the red Viper versus
the mountain of season five it just
feels like something that Dan and Dave
would take advantage of it's like let's
put the two best fighters that we can
find against each other that builds on
one of the show's best strengths big WTF
moments built for the age of social
media I know everyone wants cleganebowl
but I feel like
is the next best thing Aereo versus
brawn the interesting thing about the
Doron characters is that I'm not
expecting any of the sand snakes to be
killed off but that is totally possible
- but really the one I'm gonna go with
is bran moving back up to the reach in
the veil now Brienne but not Podrick and
little finger little finger would be the
bigger WTF just because he's a bigger
character but I feel like they could
lose Brienne get maximum WTF and it
wouldn't ruin any big overarching plots
yes Brienne is looking for Catlins
children but I don't I don't feel like
that is critical to endgame whereas the
plans that Littlefinger is making are
much more grand so that's why I feel
over the two of them Brienne would be
the more likely candidate and what I'm
hoping is is they tie it into the Sansa
plot I'm gonna be doing a dark Sansa
video probably as one of my character
videos pretty soon I'll explain a little
bit more about how I think that's gonna
work because I think they'll be giving
her aspects of the Lady Stoneheart
character and logically like the best
WTF kill they could make in that area
would be the Brienne character just
because of the way it ties back to the
Catelyn Stark storyline so moving it to
the east now I'm just gonna bypass
Braavos I feel like most of the kills
that are made in the Bravo storyline as
part of that with Arya's character are
gonna be pretty close to the books
there's just like a lot of characters
they're not doing so it's not an issue
but moving down to marine that's where
most of the characters are gonna be
starting with grey worm there's a scene
in the trailer where Miss Ann dies going
in for what looks like a kiss but she
could be kissing him as he's dying
it definitely looks like they're doing
the brazen beasts so there will be some
big conflict going on in marine I feel
like grey worm would be the first to
sacrifice himself to save Daenerys surge
or is also on my list but he seems like
kind of a coward right now he might end
up dying in these fighting pit scenes
that we see here killing those two
characters would be big WTF but it's not
gonna ruin any of her endgame I feel
like one of the big strengths of the
Daenerys character right now is that
she's not shackled to any men you know
she has a lot of men who are advisors to
her but it's not like when she was with
Khal Drogo and she was riding shotgun
she is the leader now so even though his
door is a big part of the story I feel
like they could also kill him just
because there are a number of other
characters that he's associated with
that the show isn't doing he does have a
really interesting plot in the books
that I'll let you guys read if you
haven't read it yet but if they do the
same thing that they do with the
Ironborn and they they just don't think
dude a lot of that side story then
there's not as big of a reason to keep
him on the show so his door is also high
on the list if you have read the books
and you want to do a little more Theory
crafting it doesn't seem like they're
doing the green grace character so I
think that they'll tide the green grace
character storyline to his door and then
kill him as part of that I'm just trying
to be as vague as possible for people
who haven't read the books a couple of
the characters in the show have already
caught up with their book storyline
Daenerys is not one of them they're
still like all of book five that they're
gonna do during season five moving up to
the wall now though so mance rayder
is like the highest on my hit list there
will be a bunch of big characters
that'll die up at the wall but remember
these are characters that are still
alive in the books and I feel like the
show just isn't using the mance rayder
character the same way that George R
Martin uses him so they could kill him
off it'd be a major death and it
wouldn't completely ruin the show's
likely endgame they still have the Lord
of bones and arguably the bigger
character tormund Giantsbane I feel like
the biggest wildling character that they
have at the wall right now is tormund
Giantsbane mance rayder is barely a
presence in the show like he was barely
in season four so they're gonna keep
anyone alive I feel like it'd be tormund
Giantsbane he doesn't have any royal
blood in him so there's no reason for
Melisandre to sacrifice him and they'll
still need a character to help Jon Snow
rally the wildlings to help like bridge
the gap between the Nights Watch and the
wildlings Jon Snow is really good at
treating with the wildlings but he's not
like a wildling whisperer they're not
just gonna automatically do everything
he says so they're gonna need a
character inside the wildlings to bridge
that gap so beyond this list there are a
number of other characters they could
totally kill I just I purposely kept
them off just because I feel like it
gets into spoiler territory if you want
to comment on them any characters that I
didn't mention that you definitely think
that the show is gonna kill just please
use spoiler tags because there's so much
talk about characters dying I feel like
my next bonus video is probably gonna be
my dark Sansa video so be sure to
subscribe to get that but feel free to
leave me any requests I mean we still
have several weeks before the show
starts and I'm still gonna be doing a
blu-ray/dvd giveaway like each week
which reminds me congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner Corvus haibara
you win a copy the season 4 blu-ray so
be sure to message me on my channel for
details so I get your communication info
I also said I was going to announce the
winner of my Doctor Who giveaway in this
video too so congratulations to the halo
Hobbit you win the Doctor Who gave away
also just please message me on my
channel so I get your contact info
I know you guys want to know when we're
gonna get a new trailer I'm expecting
one in the next couple of weeks they
usually release about three trailers
before the season starts so they'll be
evenly spaced out don't worry there'll
be plenty more new footage if you guys
haven't been watching the DVDs you
should totally check them out they have
some great commentary tracks one of my
favorite quotes from Dan and Dave or
that they watched the South Park game of
Thrones episodes those happen before
season four started before production on
that started when they saw the stuff
that South Park was making fun of the
game of Thrones stuff they were making
fun of they changed the way they shot
certain things in season four mostly it
was just the scene with Cartman plotting
in the garden over and over and over so
they said they dramatically cut down
potential Garden exposition even though
I know there was some Cersei and Oberyn
scenes of them walking around in the
garden talking to each other I just
loved the idea though of Dan and Dave
watching South Park and saying oh man
they're totally right about this we
totally do way too much garden plotting
I know the Oscars are tonight but I
don't really care about the Oscars so
I'm gonna be doing my normal Walking
Dead video so I'll post that after the
episode airs right now while you wait
for a new game of Thrones new Walking
Dead you can click here for my Jon Snow
video in case you haven't seen it yet
and you can click here to catch up on
Walking Dead before tonight thank you so
much watching so I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives
you